so i'm here with julia quirianova the
ceo of the ukrainian investment group
smart holding
miss kirianova
your
investment group is in charge of various
key sectors within ukraine including
metals
the energy industry and agriculture as
well so how much has
the current war in ukraine affected the
running of your business
well thank you for the question and nice
meeting you uh indeed the war uh
has a very significant
impact towards our business
all the industries were down each uh
separately because of different factors
for example
metals and mining we expect to produce
only one-thirds and export one-thirds of
the production that we used to
agriculture is also more than 50 percent
will suffer from the war but the key
problem to the country now is logistics
because you know it's like
vines or it's like
blood vessels that deliver your blood
and they are uh
really destroyed now therefore we have
leakages like stolen grains by russian
troops or gems or tromboth if you
compare to blood vessels
these are
shortages with the expo channels because
black sea and azov ports are blocked
and our railway doesn't allow for
exports so we're losing like 50 percent
of our production because of the war
you were just talking about you know the
vital elements of business you have over
100 000 employees who work for your
investment group
how has it been managing
your employees in this really dramatic
time for your country
well
when
you know business is about people
so it's always a tragedy when you see
something like in ukraine happening
so first day we tried
only safety measures that's all we can
do we tried to evacuate people
as many as we can from hotspots
we organized offices in
western ukraine
and
all the processes all the chains of
communications were broken
well because of
pandemic times we have very good online
systems
and therefore
we had the means to communicate but
people were not able to communicate
they were stuck
in the situation so it took us time
to make the organization feel
a bit more alive and i started from
myself
to tell the truth so you know i was kind
of paralyzed a few days after the war
started
and then i did two things
the first one
i
just accepted
what happened and said okay
i have nothing
at all
i have no home i have nothing
no work for example i'm out of my job
and then
i realized i have myself
and that's what really
made me
start
over uh start again and come over of
everything so then we try to
do whatever we can for our employees and
to give them job and to pay them
salaries
speaking of the destruction that the war
has caused two of your uh steel plants
in mariupol were actually just destroyed
by russian
shelling including the azov style steel
plant which you know has been in the
headlines
um so much
how do you deal with the emotional shock
of that kind of thing
and how do you get over it from a
business perspective as well
we cannot
kind of deal with it in any way we just
we just have to live
to
to help
as much as we can
and to
make people
feel
that
we take care of them and
i don't know you see the the point is
that none of the businesses was prepared
we were preparing ourselves but it was
not like what we expected the scale of
this invasion the cruelty and everything
so you cannot just 100 000 people move
somewhere
when the steel mills are there you
cannot and to stop operations on time is
a very judgmental issue
you know and also the operat the some
production process needs certain time to
be stopped so all of these factor
factors
could not allow for perfect efficiency
in saving
lives
but most of our people
are
out of marijuana
we still have
some missing people
and that will be with us
forever now here at the world economic
forum uh there's been a lot of talk
about the rebuilding of ukraine
including you know in president
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky's
opening address of the forum he talked
about the need for a new marshall plan
isn't it too early to be talking about
rebuilding a country that's still at war
i think now it's more a psychological
issue because people need to see future
to feel alive that's the first one the
second one
any plans
to be realized need some some time for
preparation
and the preparation takes sometimes
very long period therefore to start now
makes sense because we believe we'll win
and what concrete measures need to
happen in order to to start that
rebuilding
process including for for your business
including for those steel plants for
example
first of all we need to have all our
territories back
that's the first one and second each
business will
analyze
what's happened actually
and we'll remodel it completely
we're hundred percent sure we're warmed
back to where we were
there is new technology
everything is moving forward and ukraine
deserves these best technologies to be
implemented so rebuilding doesn't mean
just infrastructure
or houses which is obvious it means
business we need to have uh industrial
strategies how we treat each industry in
ukraine how much we invest how we
support all the new trends of
decarbonization
ecological all principles to be
implemented this is where we want to be
and what would you tell
international businesses including here
at the forum who are maybe hesitating
and thinking about the risks of
investing
in a business in ukraine
in a country at war once again
well
unfortunately they will be hesitating
still
some time i'm not sure
all the investments will run exactly and
flow exactly into ukraine after the war
ends
it will go to infrastructures for some
state projects but private private
business is something different
and you know
us as ukrainian business we were walking
up to working up to european standards
in many industries we implemented
corporate corporate governance we were
ready for
leveraging
for partnerships for
you know and i think uh um
i hope that this
this is a window of opportunities where
finally ukrainian business and the isn't
the focus
all we need is funds
we would need some technology and that's
it the rest we can do ourselves we're
very clever and hardworking nation
believe me
so what future then do you see for
ukrainian businesses including your own
going forward
well
i'm optimist during all my life
during all the crisis we had and in the
developing market you cannot survive if
you're not an optimist
so anyway i love my country i believe in
it i believe in its future and it's
sincere with all my heart so the the the
future is
there and
i think hard work will will bring us any
future we wish
yulia kirianov thank you very much thank
you
you